hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain a fresh
horror and thriller fiction movie with
an unexpected plot twist called antidote
the man hanging himself in a building
there is a married couple named sharon
and costas
sharon wakes up and says to her husband
that her stomach suddenly hurts
they immediately go to the hospital with
their child
there the doctor says that she has acute
appendicitis and her appendix has
ruptured the doctor also schedules an
emergency operation to be performed on
that day
when the operation is about to start she
is seen in a different place with her
hands tied to the bed
after that a doctor named aaron
helenbach comes to the room and
straightaway opens the handcuffs then
she inquires about her whereabouts now
and the doctor informs her that she has
complications with her surgery causing
her to experience anxiety he says that
he will give some medicines to treat her
illness and then leaves her alone
she sees that her surgical scar on her
stomach has suddenly healed the doctor
comes back to her room and sharon asks
him why the surgical scar on her stomach
is healed so quickly he says that they
have an unusual treatment method in this
place
when he gives the medicine sharon
refuses it and runs out of the room
outside she finds another doctor and
wants to borrow the doctor's phone for a
call but the doctor wants to arrest her
instead
in the end she decides to enter another
room that has another patient in it as
she asks for the exit the patient states
that she must be new to this place
finally the doctor is able to catch her
and gives her a sedative
back in sharon's room she tells aaron
that her family will look for her but
then he replies that no one will look
for her then the doctor locks her in the
room and then she sees a patient whose
eyes were gouged out
later she hears a knock from someone in
the next room
she receives a message through a hole in
the wall from someone named everett she
replies to the message by asking what
kind of hospital they are currently
living in and she is shocked to get the
answer that it isn't a hospital
shortly after she hears everett
screaming for help and aaron suddenly
re-enters her room and asks her about
the past that she deeply regrets
she lies saying that she has nothing to
regret but the doctor tells her not to
lie
he also finds the conversation between
her and everett he then invites her to
check her vital signs
in the hallway he informs her that she
is allowed to socialize with other
patients except hanging around the place
in another room she meets cassandra then
a former criminal leicester a sociopath
rezone and finally a lawyer everett the
man next to her room sharon asks everett
what happened last night and then he
tells her that the doctors cut his
tongue but after a while it grew back to
normal cassandra also adds that this
place is a trial ground where she was
just burned alive
a few moments later the alarm sounded
and they immediately returned to their
respective rooms the scene then moves to
sharon's past as she stares at a grave
later she sees a patient being taken by
the doctors forcibly and everett swiftly
comes into her room
he tells her that they are some kind of
guinea pigs for a program and aaron
tells him that they can get out of the
place at most three months from now the
patient who had been brought by the
doctor has returned and out of curiosity
she chooses to enter his room
she asks what has been done to him and
he tells her that the doctors have
castrated him aaron goes to his room and
injects the recovery serum on him and
tells sharon that the castration he went
through was the result of his own
behavior earlier
soon sharon desperately persuades ever
to run away from the place but he
refuses and tells her to carry out her
treatment at all times
finally she decides to go alone and the
hallway she finds someone who is banging
his head against the wall continuously
in a room
unfortunately aaron finds her and takes
her back to his room
he shows a picture of the man who hanged
himself at the beginning of the film
he asks her to explain about that person
it turns out that the man is nico and he
was a piano tuner according to her
statement they used to be a couple and
he died by hanging himself
ten pounds of drugs were also found on
his piano aaron says that he tries to
help her but he thinks that she's still
not ready with everything
sharon then sneaks out again and she
sees nico who suddenly comes out of a
room
she follows him and finds his piano and
the rope used to hang himself in a room
she is taken by another doctor and ends
up being tortured with her legs cut off
unexpectedly later aaron stitches her
leg back after that incident and her leg
is immediately able to move again
it's all caused by a serum called bms he
also says that the way things work in
this place is like that if she keeps
trying to escape
back to sharon's past when she met her
husband who turned out to be a detective
who was investigating her ex's suicide
then she's approached by rizzone who
wants to talk to her but she decides to
leave him alone and goes to everett's
room
she tells him that she met her
ex-boyfriend who had died 10 years ago
everett who hears about this is
immediately shocked and goes to aaron's
room instantly to make sure when he can
get out of the place even though in this
place there are also people who have
lived for 10 years
aaron asks him to meet with the
management but he is brought back by the
doctors to have his tongue cut again
in sharon's past her husband asked her
about the connection between nico and
the drugs found but she lied that she
didn't know anything about it later she
follows a staff working in that place
and she accidentally sees a door that
looks like a garden on the outside
unfortunately it is just her
hallucination and in the end she is
found again by aaron back to her past
again the detective visits her house and
informs her that nico's suicide case has
been closed with nico did commit suicide
later on she visits cassandra's room and
asks her to run away from the place but
then aaron comes and tells her to go
back to her room
she uses the opportunity to
intentionally drop herself on aaron's
body and stealthily takes his key
the opportunity gets even better when
another doctor informs him that there is
a patient having seizures
sharon shows cassandra the key she has
obtained and they head straight for
aaron's room to look for a map of the
place
they disguise themselves as doctors to
walk down the hall but unluckily a
doctor is aware of their existence and
immediately surrounds them
cassandra threatens them with a knife
but ends up cutting her own throat with
a knife giving sharon time to escape
lester quietly follows her from behind
when lester sneaks to cut her from
behind suddenly rezone comes for help
and takes her away into a safe room
turns out he saved her because he wants
to rape sharon
fortunately she is able to stab him with
a knife
she manages to get out and sees her past
house with her ex but then again she
only hallucinates and is again tortured
by the doctors hanging herself until her
neck is injured they treat her back
until she is recovered aaron asks her
again about her past then she says that
she was a drug addict but strangely
aaron still doesn't believe her for the
umpteenth time
she goes to everett's room knowing that
he died in a terrible accident then she
sees aaron comes out from cassandra's
room and she decides to go in
knowing from cassandra's story of how
she died sharon concludes that they are
already dead and she thinks that the
place is hell
from her past it is known that in fact
she accidentally killed nico by slashing
his neck after they were high on drugs
later her husband confirmed it was by
accident and told her to forget it on
the other hand she intentionally made
nico's body look like he commits suicide
soon she goes to aaron's room showing a
book titled dante's inferno the book
tells the story of a man named dante who
goes to hell to see sinners being
tortured and then healed only to be
tormented again
but suddenly she is brought back by
someone who wants to torture her again
and it turns out that person is nico
back then sharon regrets everything she
has done and wants to pay for it by
being left to die forever hanging in
that room
nico who can't bear it finally decides
to release her and leads her to the way
out aaron appears to block them all of a
sudden he gets hit by nico
they arrive at a place between hell and
life
as she walks to the end her pulse at the
hospital suddenly throbs
the real doctors are eagerly trying to
save her
after that they see the bridge
connecting the two worlds formed by
itself
nico told sharon to cross the bridge
first however the bridge suddenly
collapsed luckily she had time to cross
into the light nico who is left behind
is brought back inside by the doctors
in the end sharon regains consciousness
in the hospital and the doctor informs
her that she had just been dead for 15
seconds during the operation
her family is happy to see her alive
again
at home she checks the obituaries on the
internet about all the people she has
met in hell and it turns out that
everything she has experienced is real
she also gives flowers and places
candles on niko's grave in accordance
with her promise to him who had helped
freeing herself from the hell
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching